>>Narrator: These first-graders
are learning all about opera...
>>Class: [applauds]
>>Teacher: Let's give
them a round of applause.
Take a bow, guys.
>>Narrator: ...and with the help of
professional singers and musicians,
they're also becoming writers.
>>Teacher: How does Papageno feel
in the beginning of the story?
>>Student: Thrilled.
>>Teacher: Very good, and
then how do they both feel
at the end of our song?
It means really, really happy.
How did they feel?
>>Student: Exuberant.
>>Teacher: Exuberance, very
good, they feel exuberance...
>>Narrator: At Corbett Elementary
School in Tucson, Arizona,
the arts enhance instruction
in math, reading, writing,
science and social studies.
>>Teacher: What words do you use
when you're at the end of a story?
>>Student: Finally.
>>Teacher: Finally, very good.
>>Narrator: The Arts Infusion
Program, now operating in more
than 44 schools, it called OMA:
Opening Minds through the Arts.
>>Joan: Opening Minds
through the Arts is a program
that utilizes the arts to
boost student achievement
and social growth, one that uses
those tools in music, writing,
visual arts and dance to
make connections for children
that are related to their
neurological development
and to their social growth.
>>Class: [sings]
>>Narrator: OMA is based on brain
research showing that the wiring
of the left to the right side of the
brain takes place between the ages
of four and twelve, a
time when children learn
from different forms of stimulation.
>>Teacher: Is there
something that we're making
with ourselves that we're forming?
Let's see.
Esteban?
>>Esteban: A pattern.
>>Teacher: A pattern; what
kind of pattern are we making?
>>Esteban: A high-low pattern.
>>Narrator: Music helps kindergarten
children learn to listen.
>>Teacher: Our very first
shape today is a triangle.
Hand on your hips.
One, two.
>>Narrator: Dance helps
second-graders learn geometry.
>>Teacher: Now put your feet apart
so you have a triangle in your legs.
>>Narrator: Fourth-graders study
science while learning the violin.
>>Teacher: How does humidity
affect our instrument?
>>Student: It makes the
strings stick to the bridge.
>>Teacher: It makes...
>>Narrator: And fifth-graders express
their creativity by composing music.
>>Teacher: So now we need
something that repeats,
a rhythm that would be here
and then it would repeat here.
>>Joyce: Opening Minds through the
Arts really is an academic program
that infuses the arts.
Because we align it with the state
standards, it gives another way
for the brain to connect to
what children are learning,
and the more opportunities that
children have to have tactile
or physical or all of those
responses that may be different
than what we are used to learning
with, the better they learn.
>>Narrator: Professional artists
from the Tucson Opera, the symphony
and the University of Arizona teach
in each classroom twice a week.
>>Kimberly: I always like to
sing things in foreign languages,
so that really helps
the students to observe,
and it puts the second-language
learners in the same boat
as the English-speaking students,
because it's in a totally different
language that no one knows.
>>Narrator: Corbett Elementary
is a neighborhood school
in a working-class section of Tucson.
Twenty percent of its students
are English-language learners.
>>Student: My house is
dirty, I have to clean it up.
>>Teacher: Yeah.
"Oh, no, my house is dirty."
>>Joyce: One of the things
that the OMA program does,
especially for our English-language
learners, is provide them
with a art form that's
connected to learning in a way
that they can connect, no
matter what language they speak.
>>Teacher: Does anybody
know what this is called
when we kind of speak-sing like this?
What do we call that in the opera?
Recitative.
Everybody say "recitative."
>>Class: Recitative.
>>Teacher: Get used to it,
because this is how we're going
to compose music when
you write your own opera.
Isn't that exciting?
>>Rachel: Professional artists
come in and they just have a wealth
of knowledge, but not only do
these artists have a firm grasp
on their art form but they're able
to come in and create lesson plans
that teach these things to students
while also integrating things
like language skills and
just 21st-century skills.
>>Student: We learned a lot of
things about opera like subtext
and how terms of opera are used,
and you get to use
your imagination a lot.
>>Student: Nice bow in your hair.
>>Student: It's a really good
way of learning, because usually
when you learn you just read it out
of the textbooks, but when you act
out stuff and talk about stuff,
it really helps you learn better.
>>Student: Don't be late.
>>Teacher: I won't.
>>Student: I won't.
>>Teacher: So then you rush off
and you say, "Good job, dude."
>>Kimberly: They want
the story to be based
around some theme from
the curriculum.
We were thinking social
studies might be the best way
to go so that we don't...
>>Narrator: Artists work
closely with classroom teachers
to plan a semester's curriculum.
>>Teacher: So my class would be
the acts that took place prior
to the Revolutionary War, so
I don't know how that would...
>>Teacher: Just tell us
what you want them to know
about them and we'll figure it out.
>>Narrator: And the school's
full-time arts-integration specialist
helps teachers reach specific
performance objectives.
>>Rachel: And we've
completed our poetry on that,
so this unit's kind of done.
>>Evelyn: Boys and girls, can you
say good morning to Mr. Jones?
>>Class: Good morning, Mr. Jones.
>>Narrator: Ninety-three-year-old
former businessman Gene Jones
initiated the OMA program by funding
a pilot project in the year 2000.
>>Gene: So we started out seven
years ago with three schools.
We're up to 20,000 kids a day
that are impacted by the program.
It's a tremendous team effort, and
to see the effects of it on the kids,
enthusiasm that they have, is
just -- it's very thrilling to me.
>>Nathan: You'll never
believe what happened today.
The queen of the night, she didn't
keep her promise, and now...
>>Evelyn: We've been working on
this opera for about a month,
and we've been describing
the emotions
that these characters are feeling.
>>Student: Why are you
so disappointed, man?
>>Student: Because the queen of the
night didn't -- broke her promise.
>>Nathan: You see a great increase of
their vocabulary from the beginning
to the end, and since we write
their own operas at the end
of the school year, they
are coming up with ideas,
so you hear it coming
right out of their mouths.
>>Student: Then they
buy new wedding rings.
>>Student: Next they
go in an airplane.
>>Evelyn: At the first quarter I
had over half my class not be able
to write a word, and since
we've been doing this regularly,
I have sentences on papers now.
I have punctuation.
I have not just one sentence; I
have maybe three, four sentences.
I am so amazed.
It works.
>>Narrator: And independent
research confirms that reading,
writing and math test scores
have dramatically improved.
>>Class: [singing] The colon
says it be a list or a quotation.
The punctuation song.
>>Narrator: Academics aside, the
kids and adults of Corbett believe
that the arts make this
a better place to be.
>>Student: I like when
the people go up on stage
and they act and they sing.
>>Student: They teach
you how to do dialogue.
>>Student: You get
to express yourself.
>>Student: It really
helped me how to write.
>>Student: There's a lot of
acting, which I really like doing.
>>Student: It's kind of fun.
>>Class: [sings]
>>Joyce: I get tears in my eyes
when I see children laughing,
enjoying their learning.
No matter what cultural background,
they can connect with the OMA program
and improve their academics,
which is a very exciting thing.
>>Class: [sings]
>>Nathan: Bravi.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.